[Music]
if you tuned in to fake new CNN or
conspiracy TV MSNBC today you would
think this was the trial of the century
Oh Jay Simpson all over again
former Trump campaign Chairman Paul
Manafort in a Northern Virginia
courtroom now facing charges over an
alleged tax evasion and money laundering
dating back to 2005 to 2007 these
charges have nothing to do at all with
the president these charges have nothing
to do with Russian collusion I'll be
shocked if Russia is mentioned once in
this trial the mainstream media on full
high alert DEFCON level 10 The Smoking
Gun against Donald Trump watch her fake
news media in action from earlier today
trial day one for president Trump's
former campaign chairman Paul Mann
afford the man now facing a slew of
charges the case against manna Ford is
also the first high-profile test of
Special Counsel Robert Moeller if for
example mr. Madoff Ford is found guilty
that makes it a real problem for the
President of the United States could
mana fork does there's still time for
him to cut a deal Paul Manafort Paul
Manafort Paul Manafort Paul mana Ford ha
Matt afford Paul Manafort Paul Manafort
Paul Manafort Paul Manafort the
president's former campaign chair is
accused of hiding at least 30 million
dollars we're gonna learn the
nitty-gritty details about Paul manna
for its financial situation a jury has
just been seated in u.s. versus Paul J
manna for did you see what color tie
Paul Manafort was wearing he did not
either because he's sat with his back to
us
there's your media obsessing over a 2005
tax case we're gonna bring you the truth
tonight everything you're watching on
the news media it's all political this
is the weaponization of very dangerous
of our justice system
yeah Paul Manafort like Lieutenant
General Flynn Michael Kohn and others
being targeted because of their one-time
association with Donald Trump and look
let me be clear I have no idea what Paul
Manafort did in 2005 6 or 7 but it
wasn't with Russia and I do know the
Special Counsel investigation is
literally trying to throw the book
they want to extract negative
information only about the president
it's the only reason why this is
happening or is the judge in this case
overseeing this case literally said
early on telling Muller's quote legal
team led by the corrupt Andrew Weissman
I don't see what relation this
indictment has with anything the special
prosecutors authorized to investigate
you don't really care about mr. mana for
it Spang fraud you really care about
what information mr. mana for can give
you that would reflect on mr. Trump or
lead to his prosecution or his
impeachment or whatever and judge TS
Ellis goes on to say that Muller wanted
to quote tighten the screws all in an
effort to make mana fort sing or compose
by the way composing means I'll say
whatever you want if you don't put me in
jail I'll make up any story you want
that's the only reason this trial is
happening now if found guilty mana for
faces for a 2005 tax case up to life in
prison over financial related charges
has nothing to do with Russia at all
nothing to do with presidents from I
think he worked for the president less
than a hundred days in fact witnesses
have been instructed to avoid using
Trump's name altogether in order to
prevent political bias from playing a
role with the jury now without a doubt
man affords aggressive prosecution from
a special counsel who is supposed to be
investigating Russia Russia Russia is
just one more clear example in the
United States of America today sadly we
have a two-tiered system of justice in
this country
anyone ever associated with president
Trump is now under the legal microscope
but Hillary Clinton 2016 exoneration
before investigation literally they were
writing it in May they don't interview
her till July three days later she's out
free and we know she committed crimes we
know the server was hacked by foreign
entities we know she violated the
Espionage Act mishandled Secret
Intelligence where is that server
era those emails why did she destroy
classified top-secret information we all
know that if any of you out there
if you were to delete subpoenaed emails
acid-wash your hard drive with bleach
pit bust up your devices with hammers
eliminate their SIM cards after they're
subpoenaed you would be charged with
obstruction of justice so the question
really tonight is why is it Hillary
Clinton on trial for violating the
Espionage Act for obstructing justice
then of course we got Clinton's dirty
Russian dossier filled with Russian Lies
to influence the election and literally
brainwash the American people and
misinformation campaigns before the
election